brother lived here he has little hope of
finding him alive
he must be buried somewhere here my
sister-in-law and my baby niece were
rescued from the rubble by the neighbors
but my brother stayed behind and was
dragged by the mud Avalanche that
destroyed their home
Silva's brother is one of 40 that died
in Lethal landslides in the seaside town
of San Sebastian
200 kilometers from Brazil's largest
city Sao Paulo
was the epicenter of devastating floods
after 600 millimeters of rain fell in 24
hours
dozens of people remain missing the
family living in this house was lucky a
62 year old man his daughter and two
grandchildren aged 10 and 15. they fled
as soon as they heard the mudslide and
the vegetation being torn down the hill
and they made it just in time before
this tree crashed into their house
Brazil's president Louisiana
visited the disaster area on Monday as
rescue operations continued
sometimes nature surprises us but many
times we challenge nature we have to
think of safe places to rebuild houses
for the people of South sebastia
says it's time the government admitted
that tragedies like these could be
avoided
people blame us for putting our lives at
risk by building our houses on the hills
in unsafe places but we have no other
options rents in the city are high and
the only way we can afford a roof over
our heads and put food on the table is
by building our own shacks and we don't
have cheap housing Ludmila escaped the
landslide with her husband and one month
old baby like many of the 2 000 people
who lost their homes or were forced to
leave she took refuge in the nearby
Church
the church and thousands of volunteers
were forced to help Gathering clothes
water and food for the flood victims we
house 300 people but are expecting more
to come and will soon run out of space
while some neighbors are helping the
rescue teams other offer encouragement
with songs and pray for the rain to stop
Monica and archive Al Jazeera so
Sebastian Brazil